Shure: 咱们发币的这个问卷准备几个到几个
Shure: For our coin issuance, how many surveys should we prepare?
Shure: 一个到5个
Shure: One to five?
Shure: 还是5个到十个
Shure: Or five to ten?
Lucia: 好问题
Lucia: Good question.
Jake:一个两个呗
Jake: One or two.
Jake:一或2
Jake:一份两份
Jake: One or two copies.
Jake:一份两份行不
Jake: One or two copies, is that okay?
Shure: 就两种
Shure: Just two kinds.
Jake:啊这么多
Jake: Oh, that many?
Jake:行可以
Jake: Sure, that works.
Jake:1-4分吧一给一个那个沙雕的
Jake: Let's say 1-4 points, one for something silly.
Jake:比方说爱因斯坦还是牛顿还是那个谁
Jake: Like, Einstein or Newton or someone else.
Jake:什么尼亚森还是还是修硕
Jake: Like, Nyason or Shure.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Katrina: 剪刀你们知道在啊
Katrina: Do you know where the scissors are?
Katrina: 你手上有剪刀
Katrina: Do you have scissors?
Katrina: 那把红剪刀呢
Katrina: Where are the red scissors?
Lucia: 对有一个
Lucia: Yes, there's one.
Jake:好的
Jake: Got it.
Lucia: 是的那把红剪刀好用一点
Lucia: Yeah, the red scissors work better.
Lucia: 但我也没找见
Lucia: But I couldn't find them.
Katrina: 真的
Katrina: Really?
Lucia: 我靠难剪啊
Lucia: Damn, it's hard to cut.
Alice:他只有900
Alice: He only has 900.
Shure: 他们在上没
Shure: Are they online?
Jake:没问题
Jake: No problem.
Shure: 问他们在上面干嘛
Shure: Ask them what they're doing online.
Jake:我也没办法
Jake: I don't know either.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Jake:呵呵呵没问题
Jake: Hehe, no problem.
Shure: 这几个摄像头的SD卡满了
Shure: The SD cards of these cameras are full.
Shure: 没问题我也没办法呵呵呵
Shure: No problem, I don't know what to do either, hehe.
Shure: 完了杨老板开始破罐破摔
Jake:呵我能有什么办法
Jake: Haha, what can I do?
Jake:日来替卡办
Jake: Replace the cards.
Shure: 杨老大不行了
Shure: Jake can't handle it anymore.
Jake:哈哈哈没不慌
Jake: Haha, don't worry.
Alice:我们周一的安排是什么
Alice: What's our plan for Monday?
Jake:周一拆房子
Jake: We're tearing down the house on Monday.
Jake:对
Jake: Yes
Lucia: 房子星期天装修好
Lucia: The house will be finished on Sunday.
Jake:对星期一拆料对
Jake: Yes, and we will remove the materials on Monday.
Lucia: 我觉得我上
Lucia: I think I...
Lucia: 我以前好像听过一个跟很像
Lucia: I've heard something similar before.
Lucia: 刚才这个对话结构的笑话
Lucia: This conversation structure is like a joke.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
Lucia: 就是周周天正好周一拆这个
Lucia: It's like, Sunday finishes, and Monday we remove it.
Jake:ok
Jake: Okay
Lucia: 但我忘记是怎么一回事了
Lucia: But I forget how it went exactly.
Jake:OK OK
Jake: OK OK
Jake:OK
Jake: OK
Jake:行
Jake: Alright
Shure: 除了问卷还有什么吗
Shure: Is there anything else besides the survey?
Jake:好
Jake: Okay
Jake:倒吧
Jake: Let's start
Shure: 我刚开哈哈哈哈
Shure: I just started, hahaha
Lucia: 接力赛了成
Lucia: It's like a relay race now.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yes
Shure: 我这开的是不是有点多余了
Shure: Did I start too much?
Jake:你不多余
Jake: No, you're good.
Jake:你开的挺好
Jake: You did well.
Alice:那我是不是可以下班了
Alice: So can I leave now?
Alice:我去洗澡了
Alice: I'm going to take a shower.
Jake:对你可以下班
Jake: Yes, you can leave.
Alice:明天是不是我们要早点起来上钟啊
Alice: Do we have to get up early tomorrow for work?
Jake:呃对
Jake: Uh, yes.
Alice:对这是什么材质
Alice: What's this material?
Alice:塑料吗
Alice: Plastic?
Lucia: 我现在深深怀疑
Lucia: I'm really doubting now.
Lucia: 我明天能不能把自己房子装修完
Lucia: If I can finish my house tomorrow.
Jake:你现在还差多少
Jake: How much do you still have left?
Lucia: 嗯我得把这个玩意给他剪下来
Lucia: Well, I need to cut this part out.
Jake:我们可以有
Jake: We can...
Jake:我们可以找人帮你来做
Jake: We can get someone to help you.
Alice:我可能需要一个小时
Alice: I might need an hour.
Lucia: 啊我
Lucia: Ah, I...
Alice:你明天几点上钟
Alice: What time do you start work tomorrow?
Shure: 明天
Shure: Tomorrow...
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yes
Jake:明天9点
Jake: Tomorrow at 9.
Alice:9点 9点晚吗
Alice: At 9? Isn't that too late?
Jake:9点可以啊
Jake: 9 is fine.
Jake:9点把眼镜塞
Jake: At 9, I'll give you the glasses.
Jake:其实对九九点也9点
Jake: Actually, 9 is fine for both of you.
Jake:你们基本上都在自己房间里面活动了
Jake: You guys are mostly in your rooms anyway.
Jake:所以说9点直接把眼镜塞给你们
Jake: So at 9, I'll just hand you the glasses.
Jake:你们自己搞去吧
Jake: You can take care of it yourselves.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Alice:还需要他把快递拿过来
Alice: We still need him to bring the package over.
Alice:还有快递没拿
Alice: There's still a package we haven't picked up.
Jake:还有快递
Jake: There's still a package.
Jake:那快递他妈可慢了
Jake: That package is so slow.
Jake:呵呵呵
Jake: Haha.
Alice:那那他要自己去拿吗哈
Alice: So, does he have to get it himself?
Jake:自己自己拿也更慢的
Jake: If he gets it himself, it will be even slower.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:呵呵呵呵呵呵
Jake: Hahahahaha.
Lucia: 我们今天去的路上还顺便去了一趟彩店
Lucia: We even stopped by the lottery shop on our way today.
Alice:刮了吗
Alice: Did you scratch?
Jake:进他亏了20
Jake: He lost 20 bucks.
Lucia: 对然后每每人刮了一张
Lucia: Yeah, and each of us scratched one.
Jake:捐了20万福利彩票福利了20块钱
Jake: Donated 20 bucks to the lottery welfare fund.
Shure: 只有他挣了10块
Shure: Only he made 10 bucks.
Lucia: 实现盈利的只有他
Lucia: He's the only one who made a profit.
Lucia: 每个人都买了
Lucia: Everyone bought one.
Lucia: 但最后实现盈利的只有他
Lucia: But he's the only one who profited.
Jake:最后你还是行了
Jake: In the end, you still did well.
Shure: 我本来是平了
Shure: I broke even initially.
Shure: 然后最最开始最后又给他allin回去
Shure: Then at the very end, I went all in again.
Jake:结果
Jake: And the result?
Jake:还亏了20是吧
Jake: You still lost 20, right?
Shure: 是的就相当于亏了20
Shure: Yes, it’s equivalent to losing 20.
Lucia: 算一下这个赔率
Lucia: Let's calculate the odds.
Shure: 好那明天我们在上面进行知识问答
Shure: Okay, tomorrow we'll have a quiz session.
Shure: 还是在下面
Shure: Upstairs or downstairs?
Jake:在上面上面
Jake: Upstairs, upstairs.
Jake:椅子下面吃东西
Jake: Eating under the chair.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:包括外面
Jake: Including outside.
Jake:是你记得调酒
Jake: You remember to mix the drinks.
Alice: 那明天那个甜品啊调酒那些准备的
Alice: So, the desserts and drinks for tomorrow, are they prepared?
Jake:早上开始干
Jake: Start working on them in the morning.
Alice:那他们什么时候装修房子
Alice: When are they renovating the house?
Jake:呃装修房子
Jake: Uh, renovating the house...
Lucia: 我们明天早上
Lucia: Tomorrow morning.
Jake:装修房先把自己房子给装修好
Jake: Renovate your own house first.
Jake:然后没啥事了下去做做
Jake: Then if there's nothing else, go downstairs and help out.
Jake:就是帮帮忙去
Jake: Just lend a hand.
Jake:对因为我们有一些同学同志
Jake: Yeah, because some of our classmates and colleagues...
Jake:他他没有房子要装修
Jake: They don't have houses to renovate.
Jake:哈哈哈对
Jake: Hahaha, right.
Shure: 我的房子
Shure: My house...
Jake:太完美了
Jake: It's perfect.
Jake:不需要装修
Jake: Doesn't need renovation.
Shure: 比比较朴素
Shure: It's pretty plain.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Alice:花里胡哨
Alice: Flashy.
Shure: 我不喜欢花里胡哨
Shure: I don't like flashy.
Jake:然后我们还有一些剧组人员
Jake: And we also have some crew members...
Shure: 我不喜欢花里胡哨
Shure: I don't like flashy.
Jake:也没有房子
Jake: ...who don't have houses.
Jake:或者他的房子不在这个地方
Jake: Or their houses aren't here.
Jake:这也不需要装修
Jake: So no need for renovation.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Jake:就那些剧组可以帮各位装修
Jake: The crew can help you with renovations.
Jake:如果有有需要的话
Jake: If needed.
Shure: 明天剧组成员帮我写论文吧
Shure: How about the crew helps me write my thesis tomorrow?
Alice:明天剧组都来吧
Alice: The whole crew should come tomorrow.
Jake:都来都会来
Jake: They'll all come.
Jake:放心都会来
Jake: Don't worry, they'll all come.
Jake:拖家带口的来
Jake: With families in tow.
Shure: 拖家带口谢
Shure: With families in tow, thanks.
Jake:谢明茹不拖家带口吗
Jake: Isn't Xie Mingru coming with family?
Shure: 谢斌竹拖啥家呀
Shure: What family does Xie Binzhu have?
Jake:我问问他谢斌竹呢
Jake: I'll ask him, where's Xie Binzhu?
Shure: 其实他女朋友也不在北京啊
Shure: Actually, his girlfriend isn't in Beijing.
Shure: 怎么北京找了个分部是吗
Shure: Did he find a branch in Beijing or something?
Alice:洗澡了
Alice: Taking a shower.
Jake:你问问
Jake: Ask him.
Lucia: 啊对
Lucia: Ah, right.
Lucia: 我今天也得洗个澡估计
Lucia: I think I need to take a shower today too.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey.
Shure: 那他们今天晚上回去吗
Shure: Are they going back tonight?
Shure: 刘帅回去是吧
Shure: Choiszt is going back, right?
Jake:他应该应该
Jake: He should, should.
Jake:都回去
Jake: They're all going back.
Shure: 都回去是吧嗯
Shure: They're all going back, right?
Jake:没关系
Jake: It's alright.
Lucia: 我好想把这玩意直接贴墙啊
Lucia: I really want to stick this thing directly on the wall.
Jake:直接贴墙上
Jake: Stick it directly on the wall.
Lucia: 因为咱因为我又害怕到时候撕不下来
Lucia: Because, I'm afraid I won't be able to peel it off later.
Lucia: 因为咱这剪刀太难用了
Lucia: Also, these scissors are awful.
Lucia: 我根本给他剪不齐
Lucia: I can't cut it straight at all.
Jake:哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh.
Lucia: 就是人家本来是这样的
Lucia: It's supposed to be like this.
Lucia: 看哦就这意思
Lucia: See, that's the idea.
Lucia: 不知道这粘了会不会留印但是就
Lucia: I don't know if it will leave a mark once it's stuck, but...
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Lucia: 因为我没想到他是在一张纸上的
Lucia: I didn't realize it was on a piece of paper.
Lucia: 我以为他一个就是这样的哦
Lucia: I thought he was just like that.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 我就直接把他往上
Lucia: So I just went ahead and...
Lucia: 就拿个美人纸一bia就完事了
Lucia: Just grabbed a piece of paper and slapped it on.
Jake:是
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia: 吃了没有生活经验的亏
Lucia: Lack of life experience, I guess.
Lucia: 然后想想这个这样其实也行
Lucia: But then I thought, well, this way actually works too.
Lucia: 但是就是他这个这个边就不好看
Lucia: But the edges just don't look good.
Jake:剪不了吧
Jake: Can't cut it, huh?
Lucia: 剪剪到是能剪
Lucia: I can cut it.
Jake:我来剪一刀
Jake: Let me cut it once.
Lucia: 但是就是很难很难把它剪齐
Lucia: But it's really hard to cut it neatly.
Lucia: 因为这个剪刀太难用了
Lucia: This scissors are just too hard to use.
Jake:好吧
Jake: Alright.
Lucia: 如果有另外那个剪刀的话还好点
Lucia: It would be better with another pair of scissors.
Lucia: 哎
Lucia: Sigh...
Lucia: 先把这个
Lucia: Let’s first...
Lucia: 我
Lucia: I...
Jake:确实挺难用
Jake: They really are hard to use.
Lucia: 是吧
Lucia: Right?
Jake:但是可能还是可以剪
Jake: But maybe it can still be cut.
Lucia: 官方认证的难捡
Lucia: Officially certified as hard to cut.
Jake:对勉强可以剪嘛
Jake: Yeah, barely manageable to cut.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Lucia: 我给墙上贴满美文纸
Lucia: I'll stick beautiful papers all over the wall.
Lucia: 然后把这个贴在美文纸上
Lucia: Then stick this on the beautiful papers.
Jake:可以可以可以
Jake: Sure, sure, sure.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 弱智程度堪比弱智吧了
Lucia: As dumb as it gets, right?
Shure: 那我的眼镜是不是又可以关了
Shure: So, can I turn off my glasses again?
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Lucia: 同想问是可以关了吗
Lucia: I was wondering if I could turn them off?
Lucia: 我就去洗澡了哈
Lucia: I'm going to take a shower then.
Jake:可以啊可以啊关了吧
Jake: Sure, sure, turn them off.
Shure: 随便漫无目的走一会吧
Shure: Let's just wander around aimlessly for a bit.
Lucia: 耶
Lucia: Yay.
Lucia: 哎按错键
Lucia: Oops, pressed the wrong button.
Jake:哎呀给你修那个点
Jake: Oops, let me fix that for you.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Jake:呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehe.
Shure: 撞到我了
Shure: You bumped into me.
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Shure: 快说对不起
Shure: Hurry up and say sorry.
Jake:对不起
Jake: Sorry.
Lucia: 啊还是很整齐的
Lucia: Ah, it's still very neat.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia: 您剪的这个
Lucia: The way you cut it.
Jake:下了两刀
Jake: Just two cuts.
Shure: 我们结束了
Shure: We're done.
Shure: 问卷那弱智问题要有一些吗
Shure: Should we include some dumb questions in the questionnaire?
Jake:可以有一些给我发一点
Jake: Yeah, include a few, send them to me.
Lucia: 为什么陨石总能落在陨石坑里
Lucia: Why do meteorites always fall into meteorite craters?